la Kavya madam Thunder lion epoxies
Philippe opposition adopted Audrey
Donald Carter de la reponse de la camisa
Monica Lee's you can avoid second form
of the press service highly reputed
everything techniques you ladies are on
opposition appreciate the Castillo
córdova was to donate you're pretty
serious super care for yet Haiti but I'm
not because you don't use a Nepali yes
thank you good morning in the present
circumstances fighting to save people's
lives and to protect people's livelihood
is the overriding mission of all public
authorities across the European Union
and the Commission is to doing just that
when Europe was freezing up with
uncoordinated border closures and export
bans we acted to keep Goods and key
personnel moving to where they were
needed that was the most urgent tasks
and I think that things are improving
right now in parallel we move to give
the Member States all the breathing
space they needed to provide the
necessary oxygen to their economies
their business and the workers so how
did we do that we put in place the most
flexible state aid framework ever it is
unprecedented and we triggered for the
very first time the general escape
clause and this allowed a massive
injection of liquidity into the European
economy the ECB launched purchasing
programs and the EIB provided a
dedicated Korona response to give loans
to small and medium enterprises hit by
the corona crisis all of this has been
done in record time and it helped keep
the European economy on its feet
but behind these big concepts are people
so today
besides liquidity and other support we
are introducing a new proposal to kind
of preserve the the vibrant heart of the
European economy and this is it's
skilled workforce the lockdown paralyzed
the demand and it paralyzed the supply
many companies are now left with no
income and if we do nothing they have to
layoff their workers their employees and
this has as a consequence when the
engine will restart when the world
economy will restart they will not have
the skilled workforce they need to take
the offers so we will lose markets and
this will limit our recovery and this is
why we introduce today sure sure is
Europe supported short time work it can
mitigate the effects of the recession it
keeps people in work it enables
companies to return to the market with
renewed vigor the Commission will
provide loans to those member states
that need them to strengthen their short
time work schemes these schemes now
exist and are planned straight across
the European Union so sure can benefit
all member states who want to use it we
can mobilize one hundred billion euros
to do this and this will be made
possible thanks to Member States
guarantees of 25 billion and this this
is European solidarity in action the
structural funds can also be of help
here to keep people in employment we
take out conditions to ease the access
to European money
so full flexibility across regions
across priorities in every country we
recognize that member states already
investing massively to deal with the
corona crisis and therefore there is no
reason to ask them for additional
national funding all of this will allow
member states to access all the
remaining funding that they are entitled
to and this very quickly these are the
central plans of today's proposal we
have also adopted other measures to help
in particular fishermen and the most
vulnerable in society for those
proposals to become reality I count on
Parliament and council to act swiftly
this huge package we have today is our
second step in our response to the
corona crisis to date the European Union
that is the European institutions and
member states have mobilized two
thousand seven hundred seventy billion
euros and this is the largest answer to
European crisis ever given but we need
to start preparing the long-term
recovery and this will take a lot of
strength and a lot of breadth and there
the European budget the so-called mff is
our strongest it is our most important
instrument it is established it is
trusted by all Member States and it is
accepted as an outstanding tool of
investment and convergence so I think
the next European budget as a central
pillar will have to embody our response
to the corona crisis thank you
thank you very much a president we have
received many questions the first that
we will take is from Anna Nunez melara
from Spanish television Telecinco has
the European Commission talked with
Member States in order to be sure that
it will get the 25 billion guarantee
which country has shown interest in
participating and in this line when do
you expect this money will get to Spain
or Italy first mentioned sure at the
European Council so to all heads of
state and government in our last
European Council I am an ongoing contact
with the heads of state and government
and indeed I followed up with some of
them explicitly on the instrument of
sure those have spoken to but we're
interested they were open and they were
positive and this is important so now we
put forward our proposal it will be
discussed in the Eurogroup and we're
confident of quick adoption second
question from fa hands from the estonian
public broadcasting is there enough
political support for the plan among
northern states who have been resisting
the idea of corona bombs and at the same
time would it be enough to help
countries hit hardest like Italy and
Spain
well the northern states were the first
one to introduce these state-funded
short-time work schemes and they made
very good experience with it because the
principle that when a crisis hits and
mostly a crisis like this one that is an
external shock is a symmetric shock and
it hits healthy companies and strong
business when such a crisis hit the most
important part is to keep people in the
companies so therefore the sure scheme
is the guaranteeing pillar because when
you keep them in the companies the
knowledge stays in the business and in
the company and then the moment the
world economy picks up again
those companies can take the order and
recover quickly so the northern states
made very good experience with that and
it helped them to recover stronger from
the last crisis we did have sure is our
proposal it's therefore an excellent
instrument I think what I just explained
to help people to help business and to
also help stabilize consumption and
social security because when people have
an income from their work they are able
to pay into the Social Security system
of course they're able to consume so it
is a good instrument and on top the way
it is financed it is tangible European
solidarity will it be enough we are
talking about 100 billion euros of loans
and it is an enormous amount of money
and this comes on top of all I mentioned
before so this is a massive support of
the European Union that is laid forward
here all right we now have a question
from Augustine palooka from journalists
Croatia our EU member states were not
members of the eurozone going to have
the same access to assistance from
different initiatives from the
Commission the ECB and others to deal
with the consequences of the coronavirus
we see many debates mentioning always
the eurozone so it would be good to know
if non-euro member states are in a
different position or not sure is for
all 27 member states so every member
state has access to shore the we now
move to a question from Jim Bronson from
the Financial Times
to what extent should the next MSS be
retooled and leveraged into an
instrument to finance the economic
recovery from the pandemic how far will
the commission go in redesigning it well
first of all we all know that we need in
this crisis quick answers and we cannot
take one or two or three years to invent
new tools the MFF
is the strongest tool we do have it is
trusted everyone knows it so it's very
transparent it's a powerful tool it's an
accepted tool by all Member States and
all heads of states and government and
indeed we want to shape the MFF in such
a way that it is a crucial part of our
recovery plan
I think the MFF needs to be or the next
European budget needs to be a very
strong investment signal and I think the
European budget is the best expression
of solidarity and responsibility of
Member States it has to mirror our that
our interests and our investments are
strategic and they're strategic for the
future so because the priorities will
not change the priorities will be
digitalization decarbonisation and
resilience for the European Union and
here the MFF the budget plays a big role
many are calling right now for something
which is called this Marshall Plan well
I think the European budget should be
the Marshall Plan we are laying out
together as a European Union for the
European people thank you we now have a
question from Mastan CAI apologies if
I'm not pronouncing it correctly for
Morgan a reason he lands post in Denmark
the Danish government is preparing for
gradually reopening society after Easter
does the Commission believed that this
is a good idea why or why not and should
reopening of the different member states
be coordinated and agreed on a European
level yes
during the last European Council the
member states have tasked the European
Union to prepare a coordinated approach
to an exit strategy today it's too early
to speak about that but we have to
prepare for stepwise reopening in due
time therefore it's the right time to
think about it right now the Member
States
recognize that they should not repeat
the mistake made at the beginning of the
crisis so we should develop criterias we
should develop a roadmap or path how to
proceed in the exit strategy of course
there will be different timelines for
different regions so the spread of the
virus will be important the capacity of
the ICU beds will be important the
reinstalling of supply chains will be
important and you can hear from my words
that for that we need a coordinated
approach on a European level together
with the Member States we now move to
another issue on which we received
questions and it concerns the rule of
law the first question is from Quentin
is from the Washington Post you released
a statement on Tuesday calling for EU
member states not to undermine the rule
of law while they are tackling the
Coheed 19 outbreak do you think the
Hungarian coronavirus bill undermined or
not the rule of law the separation of
powers and press freedom and did you
talk to the Hungarian Prime Minister
Viktor Orban to raise our concerns about
this well on contact with the Hungarian
authorities vice-president vava'u Vova
discussed these issues last week with a
counterpart the Hungarian Minister of
Justice
yesterday in college we discussed the
emergency measures in all member states
including Hungary and I understand that
member states may need to take emergency
measures to address the immediate health
crisis but I am concerned that certain
measures go too far and I'm particularly
concerned with the situation in Hungary
we will take action as necessary as we
have already done in the past emergency
measures in the corona crisis may be
necessary I acknowledge that governments
need to have tools to act swiftly to
protect public health and many member
states are putting them in place right
now
so therefore we are monitoring the whole
and mapping the whole situation but
these emergency measures have to be
limited to what it is necessary they
have to be strictly proportionate
because they they have to be adequate in
this situation they should not last
indefinitely and very important they
should be subject to regular scrutiny
thank you last question
jean-pierre Tobin's lumen de la vista
side case Amata horizontal confirm you
omit Kenny's Mutombo hair the whole
localization the de motor of the
products motor Nacional la polo in long
guerrilla if we check on monkey
illumination the cool indeed wha Dulli
new set of jewelry in Victoire follicle
is you can tell Denis Isetta hi some
future pact apollomon glass you imagine
that till the law to tell disposition so
the backdrop of those cases is the 2015
migration crisis the relocation
decisions adopted by the council at that
time we're in intended to support Italy
and Greece all member states were
required to participate in a temporary
relocation scheme Hungary Poland and
Shakya did not and today
the court found that as a consequence
they did not fulfill their obligations
this ruling is important it is referring
to the past but it will give us guidance
to the future the court is very clear
about responsibilities of member states
and we are now working on preparing the
migration packed so vice-presidents
Tina's and Commissioner Johansson have
met all the counterparts in the Member
State they have had consultations with
the European Parliament and we will now
be putting forward this pact
after Easter at the moment being we're
putting all the pieces
are necessary together okay merci
beaucoup Vanna resident Monsieur vous
avec rtcp a conference depress key
controller also has PV param breathing
techniques for the difference is le
monde develop oppositional Rami message